welcome to this video playing other car
maybe 93 it's a feeder master here from
Israel ever huge score five and a half
or 06 that sounds good okay let's go
Slav defense
yeah I really don't know the sharper
line so when I enter those kind of
territory with Knight c3 I mostly play
this set up with III it's not super
critical from black this setup but it is
some the only thing that I feel I can
play with with my limited knowledge or
maybe Bishop f4 was in precise yeah the
d4 pawn that's not good but it's okay if
he takes f3 I mean we cannot take on d4
right I have worked you one Quincy five
Bishop t6 so it's not as bad not so bad
oh it's Bishop f4 actually the the
normal move there hmm I don't know yeah
I mostly when I entered the Slav um in
in tournament chess I was mostly playing
Queen c2 queen bee three lines early on
or or even the exchange variation which
really served me well over the years
winning some games never losing even
against good players sound like Irvin la
me I had hit him once in the german
bundesliga it was a an amazingly boring
game but I gotta draw not wasn't very
exciting or very yeah a memorable game
let's say but it the opening did its job
let's let's let's put it like that okay
maybe this this one eim for threatening
me five and he cannot play
self no can i'll play you five himself i
think as i go a 59 moves 95 that looks
really bad so yeah he decided to to take
that radical course of action so let's
push the night away now we're thinking
that b5 might be interesting or maybe h3
first i think i can start with that move
taking looks good anyway now i also have
e5e five and then 94 that's also quite
interesting he doesn't have any great
squares to go to may be difficult to
save they all look good here a couple of
good continuations how to how to tell
what's what's really best
so what now
it's h four and move trying to get get
to his King that I cannot just take
either a Bishop f4 it's probably not
good there are other interesting ideas
the group d for for example trying to
double or a six I don't know spoiled for
choice many many good-looking moves
let's just chill just play play one of
those and hope that it's okay trying to
double on the D file and that look might
be handy on the fourth rank
okay so Knight f6 steady move no
if he gets everything traded on the
default it is not so not so promising
yeah but I don't see anything else and
have spent too much time now there
anything else that I can do besides
taking it maybe this this is an
interesting one if you take sat night I
can take with the night for knight c6
trying to make his Bishop look a bit
stupid on h5 yes that's the problem
maybe Quincy far though 24 maybe me up
Bishop a force also pretty pretty
awkward imitates
should be four queens 27 is just about
holding maybe looks it looks amazingly
awful but maybe Quincy seven is just
just about holding okay so i can now
jump in and okay so taking i can just
take everything check sometimes I really
slow with those things and then Knight
f6 check I saw the idea before word to
forgot about it
yeah it's a first class disaster
taking us time there
it's a clock run down hard don't don't
give me that it's really very yeah a
very poor way of resigning the game
yeah what is I don't know doing what we
can try for a quick repack recap of that
game I think Bishop d3 is right yeah
that's probably our book t1 already
forgot forgot to watch whatever dick ok
Knight b6 did he now resign no he really
let's the clock run down yeah so I went
to be three and i couldn't take on f3
and on d4 because of rook t1 and now I
year probably no no way the game is now
I ended black forfeits on time yep thank
you very much so let's go back so we'll
see five as I said he cannot take here
and here because of this ok men it's
probably not winning immediately but
it's an exchange so see five pigs pigs
and now this is already really
uncomfortable the engine wants to do
this actually yeah that also is pretty
strong very strong when he have also
keeping an edge but it's not as
convincing five and now add that that
was he five here yeah then the engine
approves looks like I made many engine
moves book before i played this first it
seems equal should have taken now at rug
t49 of eight look-see for answer would
have been strong and now ok Knight f6
just winning uh-huh I of course yeah i'm
missing simple simple tactics i'm really
oops yeah that was winning immediately I
mean this is good but of course the
other thing wins
you should have taken data entrance
gifts but ok let's have a look here it's
probably really winning uh is this Nancy
6-channel exactly this line wins the
house so that looked like a decent game
I missed some chances with it was quite
okay in general okay well thanks for
watching